You guys that were on this team last year,
it was taken from you.
Now, go out and take this from them.
I just don't like what I said
and how I acted.
Hey!
Shut up and listen to what's going on!
True change has gotta come
from the inside.
Whatever happened in the past, it's done.
Let's just worry about the future.
Somebody had said I had a gun in my dorm.
I failed two drug tests.
They ended up charging me
with a second degree felony.
What I did was unacceptable.
That's not what define me.
Let's be real,
if he wasn't a good football player,
we wouldn't be talking to him.
He's a good coach,
but he lacks of knowing his players.
Every year, it just seems
to get worse and worse with Buddy.
Get going!
I don't know if he's changed or not.
He hasn't changed towards me,
that's for sure.
What are you doing?
Every day you gotta get better!
Every single day!
This is where you see what you made of.
Let's go!
We're gonna size some rings up.
We all have to believe in ourselves.
'Cause I do believe in you.
He's down!
I don't know that I can live like this.
I'm gonna tell y'all right now,
y'all ain't gonna make fun of my shorts.
Bring 'em back, Coach!